the gyro can experience health and
Gracie's another famous jiu-jitsu
practitioner he was asked to describe
jiu-jitsu any slide I'm on a paraphrase
this I might [ __ ] it up he said he said
it was basically like I move and then
you move and then I move and then you
move forever forever those descriptions
like so if you realize how good health
and is that it becomes a terrifying
expression because it's like eventually
I'm gonna get you [ __ ] yes [ __ ] up
you're gonna get tired you're gonna be
using too much strength and you're gonna
get exhausted just like those boxers
that were throwing punches and they get
tired and the other guy would piece them
up but it's gonna be even more horrific
because you're never gonna be able to
accomplish anything you're just gonna
slowly wear out you guys just gonna keep
attacking you and you keep pushing them
off you and he's gonna keep attacking
you and you keep exploding and he's
gonna keep attacking and eventually and
then he's just gonna dominate you he's
just gonna control you you'd be great at
it dude be good for you yeah it'd be
really good for you all right what I
have to be in there with kids when I
first hears how strong jujitsu is there
was a woman named she still exists her
name's Felicia oh she's a friend of mine
she's a black belt from jean-jacques
Machado's she's super technical and she
weighs Felicia's very strong which
weighs about maybe 135 pounds and there
was a guy named Seymour butts and
Seymour butts for the porn star who had
a TV show on Showtime and he had this
idea pretty bold of him really he's
brave to do this we just decided I'm
gonna do like a jujitsu match well I've
never taken jujitsu before but I'm gonna
spar with a woman and see what happens
and this girl just [ __ ] she but she it
was she's elite man she's really good
she good yeah she teaches people yeah
she also works for the California State
Athletic Commission so I get to see her
at UFC events oftentimes in there in
California she's awesome but she's super
technical so this guy has he was doomed
he just didn't know he was a guy he's in
really good shape he's young and fit
pretty good bodies choking omits leglock
at home and I don't know what she did do
I want to remember how many times she
tapped him or what she did it with but
it was like arm bars and triangles but
again that would happen to any man who
didn't know anything and went with her
so even though she's a woman yeah just
the technical expertise it overcomes
strength it's so for a guy like you
who's a very cerebral person who likes
these sort of puzzles and figures things
out it's one of the reasons why your
comedy is so good you're excellent at
like economy of words and setting things
up in a mysterious way and then dropping
punk lies that's jiu-jitsu it's they're
similar I like that I think there's a
lot of things like that in this life
they are similar yeah
there's little things that you you learn
like little ways to move around things
that advance through these these games
and systems and you can apply that to
all these other different things
and you can apply it you into comedy
yeah
[Applause]